à combien de FPS voit l'œil humain déjà
120 images par seconde est-ce que c'est
vraiment utile à partir de quand nous
va-t-on plus voir la différence pas
facile d'y répondre nos yeux ne
fonctionnent pas en FPS la rétine 4 le
plus constant de lumière et l'envoi dans
le nerf optique jusqu'au cerveau
techniquement on voit un nombre infini
d'image à la seconde ce qui change c'est
la vitesse à laquelle on les traite le
Cortés garde l'information de la rétine
pendant environ un 15e de seconde c'est
pour ça qu'en dessous de 15 FPS on a
l'impression que l'image saccade
au-dessus l'illusion fonctionne c'est le
principe des dessins animés maintenant
le cerveau a ses limites quand un objet
va trop vite il n'a pas le temps de tout
traiter c'est pour ça que ta main
devient floue quand tu la secoue devant
tes yeux si on convertit en moyenne on
déchiffre l'information à une vitesse de
30 à 60 fps pour les plus réactifs ça
peut aller jusqu'à 75 ou 90 mais c'est
rare un jeu ascendant FPS c'est que la
frime presque impossible de voir la
différence car maintenant vous savez